have you heard according to the latest
government numbers inflation is cooling
at least slightly however it is still
very high and soaring car insurance
costs are a big concern for most
Americans let's talk overall consumer
prices they wrote 6.4 percent in January
that was from a year earlier a small
decline from December's numbers but when
it comes to auto insurance prices are
still surging they're up nearly 15
percent Manuel bojorquez looks now at
what is behind that Spike
Juan matoso lives in Miami where drivers
are spending the most on car insurance
Pioneer insurance was 2400 for six
months and it went up to four thousand
the cost to ensure his Tesla went up by
nearly 70 percent it hurts it definitely
hurts a new report by bankrate.com found
Nationwide premiums have risen more than
240 dollars on average topping two
thousand dollars a year Florida drivers
saw the biggest jump up nearly twice
that amount to almost 3 200 a year Kate
deventer authored the report there's a
lot of residents in Florida and the
population is growing then we also see a
lot of tourists which then of course add
to those busy roadways and that makes it
even more likely that an accident is
going to happen the high cost of car
insurance comes as supply chain issues
are starting to ease but the spike in
repair costs labor and Medical Care are
driving insurance rates up across the
board good morning great Florida how may
I help you Ana Karina callejas is an
insurance agent at Great Florida she
says one of the major driving forces for
Rising car premiums are claims tied up
in court most clean that are going
through to the carriers are coming in
with an attorney
so maybe a claim that could have been
closed off rather quickly is now tied up
in court
with higher and higher and higher
expenses expenses that are ultimately
passed down to Consumers her office has
been taking calls from customers to see
if they can get their rates down
sometimes they get lucky and we will be
able to find something and sometimes we
don't she was able to find Juan maroso a
policy eight hundred dollars below the
four thousand he was quoted but she says
rates will likely continue to climb you
think it will get worse before it gets
better 100 really yeah I think we're
we're not going to see
um
positive changes
maybe for like a year or two human rates
going down
right
so with that bad news some advice now
from the experts they say you should
always shop around ask your agent to
make sure you're getting every available
discount consider a car that's cheaper
to insure but above all drive safely
it's those moving violations that could
send your rates even higher Nate
Manuel on it as usual we appreciate you